cuando era chico bueno más chico estaba
mirando una serie de dibujos animados
no me recuerdo mucho de cómo se llamaba
y de qué se trataba lo que sí recuerdo
es que en algún momento apareció museo
eso había exportado un y algo que más
tarde me daría cuenta que era la
curiosidad pero los autos se vieron como
un capricho y no me dieron mucha bola
aún así sí insistiendo a cambio de tanto
esfuerzo consigue un par de libros del
antiguo egipto pero no era suficiente yo
no quería ver una momia en la televisión
en un libro yo quería un museo ya nada
era suficiente ni sergio la momia
esa foto me la sacó mi mamá
entonces mi abuelo
o la momia que se encontraba la
intendencia de montevideo después fuimos
otros museos uno de ellos el mapa museo
de arte precolombino e indígena
cuando estaba ahí descubrí que el mapa
tenía actividades y no dude en
inscribirme a una de ellas cuando él fue
la actividad me gustó entonces fui a
otra y a otra cada vez que vea el mapa
aprende algo nuevo pero no del antiguo
egipto sino de las personas que vieron
de mi país hace mucho tiempo los
indígenas
una de las cosas que aprendí fue que en
uruguay no había muchos charrúas sino
que los guaraníes fueron mayoría
un día mi mamá me dijo que el mapa
estaba buscando niños que quieran formar
parte de un consejo de niños en el mapa
me parecía una gran oportunidad para
poder participar más en el museo
el consejo consiste en un grupo de niños
que aportan ideas al museo
en la primera reunión había más gente
que todos en esta sala de ese grupo
quedamos los doce más curiosos
otra de las cosas que aprendí es que
hace mucho tiempo existe un grupo de
animales mamíferos conocidos como la
mega fauna se llaman así porque todos
los animales de este grupo pesaban como
mínimo una tonelada era mega pesados
entre este grupo estaba el dow donde es
perezoso gigante el toxodonte lama
caraqueña que es mario genial
smilodon también conocido como tigre
dientes de sable entre otros
una de las diferencias que tiene la
megafauna por el dinosaurio
es que la megafauna convivió con
nosotros en cambio los dinosaurios se
extinguieron hace millones de años
para aprender más de la megafauna fui al
arroyo vizcaíno en canelones
donde se dejaron con túnez de fósiles en
la temporada de sequía ahora los
paleontólogos colocan una especie de
represa inflable y decía del agua del
arroyo por un tiempo para sacar más
fósiles me parece una gran experiencia
en un cambio no olvidaré
como también me gustaría arte hice el
logo del museo ámbar
y un cuento de la megafauna que se llama
megafauna world como se imaginarán está
basado en su base quot
también hice un cómic de mi pieza
favorita del museo en el gorro de cuatro
puntas el gorro de cuatro puntas era
como una corona para los indígenas de
los andes
que facundo el doctor the map y no se
enoje pero el mapa es un embole
porque tiene poco dinero para esperar
las piezas una forma agradable y encima
la pieza más llamativa que teníamos se
fue otro museo era todo una réplica del
todo
eso sí dos las piezas tienen una
historia fascinante gracias a las
visitas guiadas en las actividades el
museo es muy copado
en las vacaciones de invierno el mapi
nos ofreció en los niños el consejo ser
guías en las visitas guiadas para
adultos y también hacer una actividad
para niños más chicos que son lo más
divertido de la visita es que los
adultos no estaba preparados para
responder preguntas mucho menos
preguntas de un niño
en una de las celdas del museo hay una
cana guaraní cuando la visita pase por
esa sala les pregunte como los guaraníes
ya del tronco para hacer la canoa y me
respondieron con motosierra en esa época
de existía jalando una cuerda en sello
si quieren probarlo vayan al parque no
les va a funcionar
la respuesta era con una fuerza en las
raíces
por otro lado la actividad para niños
más chicos también era complicada es
difícil organizar a niños de 3 y 4 años
algo fue un poco duro me encantó esta
experiencia
el mapa ganó dos premios internacionales
por el consejo de niños el best practice
sabor 2018 que el premio iberoamericano
de museos uno de estos bueno podemos ir
a buscar porque están muy lejos y como
les dije antes el museo tiene muy poca
plata
ahora ya jugar de mí
yo raro
lo admito soy medio raro antes de los
dos años con tan solo ver el logo de las
marcas de los autos que sería el nombre
de todas me sorprende a mí mismo a los
tres años intenté hablar con dios pero
no me contestó y me pregunté por qué no
me contesta y si no existe
para que teorías de la creación y la que
más me sorprendió fue la del big bang
según la teoría del big bang una
partícula creó el mundo lo único en el
entero universo que es indestructible se
rompió y eso creó el cosmos y me
despertó la curiosidad y comencé mis
propias teorías
ahí me di cuenta que no soy raro sé
curioso
el fin de la mitología sobre todo los
mitos de héroes griegos el que más me
gustó fue el de percy medusa
fui a méxico a escalar las pirámides
nacional de antropología en donde pude
ver mi pieza favorita el calendario
azteca
en el museo de antropología es enorme y
tiene un montón de piezas atractivos
ojalá en un futuro el mapa sea así
también fui a otros museos en uruguay
entre ellos el museo gurvich el zorrilla
en uso del mar
todo lo que les acabo de contar lo sé
gracias a mi curiosidad
yo voy hacia de la curiosidad me lleve
si yo no sigo este camino mi vida va a
perder sentido
yo no veo la curiosidad con un principio
en final yo la veo como un camino que
nunca se acaba
si les da curiosidad algo no se sientan
raros y no dejen de investigarlo
que la curiosidad nunca se acabe
[Aplausos]